[Música]
empieza la competencia estamos
emocionados con mucha adrenalina
realizamos nuestro post dentro del tubo
vacío y lo más que está llegando el
lanzamiento de cubrir ahora así que
sostenemos la respiración
esperamos lo mejor y empieza la cuenta
regresiva
[Aplausos]
detrás de estos 15 segundos se esconde
un año intenso trabajo
se trata de la competencia internacional
que cambió mi vida hace más de 5 años
yo estaba literalmente enamorada esta
competencia sólo pensaba en eso solo
quería estar en cerca de eso y todo lo
que está alrededor de eso me emocionaba
y lo curioso es que esta competencia no
solo me ha enamorado a mí ya que sino
que ha enamorado a miles de estudiantes
en todo el mundo
y es exactamente esto lo que me gustaría
hablarles hoy creo firmemente que
participan en este tipo de competencia
los estudiantes llegan a aprender cosas
que no aprenden en la educación
tradicional
por lo que este tipo de iniciativa ya
sea tecnología o de cualquier otro campo
debería implementarse en los planos de
estudios todos los colegios y
universidades en el mundo esta
competencia que les estaba comentando al
principio se trata del hype el que es un
sistema de transporte que introdujo hilo
en más que para poder viajar de una
ciudad a otra en un futuro a velocidades
de 1200 kilómetros por hora
a estas velocidades podría atravesar
costa rica- norte a sur en menos de 30
minutos
para empezar a trabajar en esta
tecnología se introdujo esta competencia
en la que participaron equipos de todo
el mundo con un objetivo súper claro
construir un prototipo también llamado
pod
el prototipo que viajará más rápido
dentro de un tubo de vacío de 12 km de
longitud sin estrellarse
estas emociones que vieron en el vídeo
no solo las tuvimos durante esos 15
segundos sino durante toda la
competencia y es que investigaciones
confirman que las emociones influyen en
el aprendizaje
los momentos que mejor recordamos son
los momentos que vivimos con mucha
emoción y lo mismo pasa con el
aprendizaje las cosas que mejor
aprendemos son las cosas que aprendimos
con más emoción con curiosidad con
alegría
probablemente la mayoría de ustedes se
acuerda del día de su graduación o tal
vez de su primer examen de conducir pero
lo más probable es que actividades que
hicimos en piloto automático como lo que
almorzamos la semana anterior
o incluso si hace una hora apagamos la
cocina ya lo olvidamos
cuando nos emocionamos nuestro cuerpo
segrega adrenalina
y está confirmado que por alguna razón
los recuerdos durante ese periodo de
tiempo se agudizan y se aprenden mejor y
eso tiene mucho sentido con mi historia
cuando yo estaba la universidad a veces
tenía que aprender fórmulas que se me
olvidaban fácilmente cuando no me
interesaban mucho pero en las
competencias cada vez me gustaban más en
general recordaba todo mucho más
claridad
un ejemplo fue con el sistema baterías
como líder del sistema de baterías tenía
la responsabilidad de asegurarme de que
teníamos suficiente potencia así que
creamos un sistema para calentar las
baterías que se basaba en una fórmula
que había perdido en algún momento en mi
carrera de física pero ya lo había
olvidado en el momento en el que supe
para qué servía esta fórmula como la
podía aplicar y que poder ganar podía
aprender de esta fórmula nunca más me
olvido
porque entonces en las universidades no
aprendemos con más emoción qué pasa si
con la misma facilidad que nos acordamos
de fiestas o eventos con amigos nos
acordáramos del contenido de clase
y este primer análisis sobre la
importancia de las emociones y el
aprendizaje
me llevó a darme cuenta de un segundo
factor que me dio las competencias y no
la educación tradicional porque no
creamos un amor por el aprendizaje es
decir que nos guste aprender por el
simple hecho de aprender
porque en lugar de que nos comparen a
todos a un mismo parámetro como por
ejemplo con exámenes porque no animamos
a que cada persona encuentre su hobby su
pasión su competencia
donde nazcan estas emociones
y es que durante las competencias de
spacex todos hacíamos lo que hacíamos
por aprender esto no era parte de una
nota de un curso no recibíamos sueldo
muchos de mis amigos no entendían por
qué yo hacía lo que hacía sin que me
pagar porque también tenía que trabajar
paralelamente para poder pagar unos
gastos pero es que a mí me encantaba lo
que estaba haciendo todo hacíamos
simplemente programación de estar ahí
por qué entonces no promover ese tipo de
iniciativas si las personas lo hacen con
tanto gusto y cada quien puede
desarrollar su propia habilidad en lugar
de estar fijándonos en una nota y esto
me lleva al tercer punto la importancia
de que las universidades y colegios
fomenten el trabajo en equipo
en esas competencias tuve la oportunidad
de trabajar con personas de diferentes
disciplinas de ingeniería de
administración de electrónica
en la educación tradicional no tuve la
oportunidad de estar cerca de personas
con personas de disciplinas tan
diferentes por ejemplo la informática o
la electrónica nunca me llamaron la
atención en el momento en el que supe
como nuestro voto funcionaba me di
cuenta lo mucho que me llevo a gustar la
electrónica y lo importante que podía
ser la informática
en costa rica por ejemplo en muchas de
las universidades las carreras son muy
especializadas
y qué pasa cuando los estudiantes
quieren cambiar de carrera muchas
gracias a la motivan porque tienen que
cursar muchos de los cursos nuevamente
lo que hace que haya un mayor índice de
deserción y este es sólo uno de los
beneficios que tiene el trabajo en
equipo en este tipo de iniciativas
en el colegio compites por una
calificación compites contra tus
compañeros pero no con tus compañeros
el aprendizaje competitivo y el estar
pendiente de lo que hacen los demás le
quitan a uno la atención en lo propio y
lo que realmente lo haría uno salir
adelante en las competencias de spacex
las cuatro las ganamos ante
universidades como the mighty delft 7 h
y yo siento que en gran parte fue porque
en cada competencia hacíamos algo que
nos diferencia a los demás si hubiéramos
estado siempre pendiente de lo que hacen
los demás no nos habríamos enfocado en
el nuestro y habríamos seguido nuestro
propio camino
en este tipo de iniciativas
las personas no son comparadas bajo un
mismo parámetro ya que cada quien
desarrolló su propia habilidad que es
indispensable para el equipo y al final
todo ganan las universidades también se
benefician del éxito de los estudiantes
y universidad por ejemplo es por ti que
ganarme las competencias recibió
financiación de baviera que es el estado
más grande de alemania y su reputación
aumentó considerablemente
yo invito a las universidades y colegios
a que disfruten estos beneficios y
fomenten este tipo de proyectos que los
estudiantes están hambrientos por tener
y a los jóvenes los invito a que busquen
su pasión su competencia su reto que los
inspira a levantarse todas las mañanas
[Música]